vous avez vu juste avant cette image de
tournée aujourd'hui cette Porsche qui
tourne super vite sur ce coin-là les
gens roulent comme des fous c'est une
c'est une zone résidentielle et on roule
beaucoup trop rapidement comment se
fait-il qu'il y a pas des dos d'âne ou
des obstacles pour les ralentir
mais il y en a puis on a en mai de
toujours de plus en plus mais évidemment
avec le nombre de routes le nombre de
rues qui existent à Montréal ça
s'apprend un certain temps juste dans le
quartier Sainte-Marie parce que c'est là
où ça s'est passé d'ailleurs c'est un
quartier que je connais bien c'est là où
j'ai été élu comme conseillère de ville
donc partenaire Rouen dans les dernières
années on a fait à peu près une
vingtaine de rues locales qu'on a mis
des dos d'âmes ou soit des affichageurs
ou encore des saillies trottoirs parce
que quand on fait une série de trottoir
vous le savez non seulement ça ça
diminue le temps de traverse donc c'est
meilleur pour les piétons mais aussi ça
augmente la visibilité mais il faut
toujours en faire plus c'est évident ça
c'est qu'est-ce que la ville peut faire
en matière d'aménagement puis après ça
j'imagine qu'on pourra
je veux revenir je veux rester sur le
centre sud parce que vous dites
on compare avec des quartiers comme
Notre-Dame de Grâce Outremont
au niveau de vie plus élevé c'est bien
peut-être pas de rapport mais en tout
cas où il y a une conscience il y a des
dos d'ânes partout mais littéralement
partout au centre sud parce qu'on est
près du pont Jacques-Cartier soucis de
mobilité on se dit ouais dans le fond on
veut pas trop ralentir les voitures
est-ce que c'est pas là le problème mais
vous le dites c'est à dire que dans le
centre sud contrairement Outremont dans
le centre sud il y a des rues de
camionnage il y a un pont qui se jette
dans le quartier attendez moi bien je
suis pas en train de dire que parce
qu'il y a des grandes artères on doit
pas protéger la sécurité des piétons les
qui sont les plus vulnérables ce que je
vous dis c'est que le centre-ville le
centre sud c'est un quartier sous
pression
parce que beaucoup de gens traversent le
centre sud pour aller travailler puis
revenir à la maison ce qui est pas le
cas autrement par exemple alors
nécessairement quand on fait des
aménagements on prend ça en
considération par exemple de laurier on
sort du pont Jacques-Cartier on roule on
arrive dans un quartier dans ses mains
peuplé alors faut travailler que la MTQ
qui dit bah sauf c'est une rue de
camionnage il faut qu'on l'assure et on
comprend mais en même temps il faut
absolument encore une fois via des
séries trottoirs et autres et je sais
elle mentionné quand on est arrivé en
poste proche de Montréal on a mis vision
zéro et ça ça veut dire que depuis qu'on
est arrivé il y a à peu près je dirais
plus de 80 écoles qui ont été sécurisées
ça faisait qu'on sécurise tout autour
des milliers
on avait un reportage hier sur
Christophe Colomb des photos radars qui
marchent pas mais je reviens au dos
d'âne parce que après un accident
tragique comme celui-là pourquoi vous
avez pas dit aux gens des travaux
publics allez sur partenaire installé un
dos d'âne demain matin on va montrer
quand on sait que le réseau de la
autoroutier ta
saturations
à Montréal qui grimpent années après
année on est rendu à plus d'un million
2021 effectivement il y a plus de
véhicules mais je reviens au centre sud
oui vous avez fait des choses oui oui on
va aller plus loin on va aller se poser
30 km/h c'est quand même que l'ambulance
roule moins vite sur Parthenay pourquoi
ne pas envoyer un signal d'enfer plus à
court terme là
on va en faire plus mais on le fait
toujours de façon graduée parce que la
dernière chose que je voudrais avoir
l'impression c'est que rien qui se fait
de Rouen juste avant là de roi à cause
que deux grands parcs on a décidé de la
fermer de roi c'est exactement là où il
y a un accident un peu plus loin on pose
des gestes extrêmement concrets mais ce
que je vais quand même c'est que parce
que Papineau on peut pas traverser
facilement parce que le pompe tunnel
vous avez peur aussi de rendre de
bloquer la ville en mettant trop
d'entrave aux automobilistes mais
écoutez c'est intéressant votre question
c'est pas tant d'avoir peur c'est d'être
consciente que il y en a autant on va
avoir de la pression par exemple du
milieu du camionnage qui dit il faut
qu'on puisse passer quelque part oui oui
mais il faut répondre oui mais moi ce
que j'essaie de vous dire c'est que la
meilleure façon puis ça c'est des études
qui disent le cours qui ait plus de
collision mortelle ou qui en a presque
plus parce que vos chiffres sont très
parlants là il faut qu'il y ait moins de
véhicules sur les routes puis il faut
rouler moins vite on peut parler de la
vitesse qu'on peut en parler tant que
vous voulez monsieur roi mais maman
donner leur faut faire se parler de
est-ce que c'est normal qu'elle est
toujours plus de voitures à Montréal à
un moment donné c'est non et encore une
fois quand une ville a été fait comme le
centre ville où on a mis un pont qui
sort en plein milieu d'un quartier
d'enseignement peuplé pour se poser des
questions mais les choix va falloir que
là même atteint quand les voitures vont
avoir de la difficulté à circuler il va
falloir que les gens se rappellent qu'on
le fait pour les on le fait pour les
personnes aînées puis on le fait pour
tout le monde
je sais que vous aimez pas quand on vous
c'est un exemple ce que Luc Ferrandez
fait dans le plateau il s'est fait
engueuler par des gens de l'extérieur de
ce quartier là autant comme autant mais
il y a fait des choses surprenantes très
loin il y a poussé très loin le bouchon
mais il y a plus il y a beaucoup moins
de transit Nord-Sud puis les gens ont
appris que c'est un quartier résidentiel
est-ce que le centre sud n'a pas besoin
d'un luxe Fernandez ou d'une politique
plus agressive c'est sûr que je vous
demande en fait
mais la réponse en fait c'est que quand
nous on met des programmes à la grandeur
de la ville qui mis sur la sécurité des
piétons pour moi c'est ce qu'on fait et
on le fait à la grandeur de la ville et
j'aimerais vous rappeler que la mairesse
devienne Marie c'est moi et quand avant
qu'on arrive en poste il y avait rien
qui était fait dans Ville-Marie mais
absolument pas et la dernière chose
encore une fois moi je passe sur la
défensive en même temps en ce moment-ci
parce que notre bilan je suis
extrêmement fier si vous voulez savoir
si on va aller plus loin oui est-ce que
dans le centre sud
plus de saillie de trottoir plus
d'obstacles pour que les grosses
voitures 4x4 ne puissent pas faire du 70
km/h sur partenaire c'est pas seulement
parce que là si vous voulez faire une
comparaison avec le plateau c'est pas
juste parce que vous parlez de vitesse
la vitesse là je vous répète pour moi
c'est pas ça le fond du problème c'est
laquelle est-ce qu'on laisse les
véhicules aller où ils veulent et là à
ce moment-là c'est ce qui s'est passé
sur le Plateau Mont-Royal alors au
moment donné soit avec des sens ou
fermer des rues mais ça ça c'est pas
populaire à dire les gens impatient
entendre ça mais vous vous rappellerez à
ce moment-là mais moi oui il y a plus
oui il y a plus de circulation mais on
aurait réduit la vitesse sur partenaire
parce que il y a une petite fille qui
est mort vous me rappellerez ça avec
plaisir
deux trois mots sur les radars photos
hier on avait un reportage de Christophe
Colomb il y a un radar photos qui aimait
pas de contravention c'est pas trop
pourquoi est-ce que c'est gouverne du
Québec pourquoi pas plus de radars
photos le voilà une solution qui est pas
si compliqué absolument les radars
photos c'est intéressant encore une fois
on travaille beaucoup avec Québec pour
pouvoir les implanter sinon c'est la
présence policière qui qui est là faut
savoir aussi un des projets qui avait
été fort intéressant sur Christophe
Colomb moi j'habite à côté comme mes
enfants allaient à l'école petit j'étais
toujours inquiète quand tu traversais la
rue Christophe Colomb alors je le
comprends très bien quand on a mis une
piste cyclable il y a deux ans pendant
toute la période estivale sur Christophe
Colomb ça l'a apaisé la circulation
Telma que tous les riverains dont les
parents disaient est-ce qu'on peut
garder ça parce qu'on sait qu'une façon
de réduire la vitesse et la circulation
c'est de rétrécir les rues en ayant
moins de circulation parce que je le
répète au moment donné il faut falloir
qu'on parle la vraie question le nombre
de voitures qui circulent à Montréal
de voitures à Montréal toujours une
augmentation c'est plus possible
entre autres et je sais que pendant la
pandémie on était sur une très belle
lancée en transport collectif les gens
ont repris leur habitude de prendre le
transport leur voiture mais il faut
encourager je pense juste au pont au
pont il fallait que la fontaine il y a
des navettes il y a plus de départ et on
voit que les jeunes n'utilisent pas tant
que ça encore où il pourrait l'utiliser
beaucoup plus vous allez dire
shopen vous pourriez pas
même si c'est vous dites pas tout à fait
en accord avec les ambulanciers mettre
un dos d'âne sur partenaire au moins
pour rappeler aux gens qu'il y a eu un
drap qui a eu un drame je sais que pour
vous c'est le dos d'âme est-ce que je
peux vous dire
je travaille avec les équipes de
villemari mes équipes et je peux vous
dire qu'il va y avoir quelque chose puis
vite
aux affaires ça peut être plus fort très
bien on va se reparler un mot parce que
je la coupe 15 ça vous inquiète on part
de grands changements de nombre de taux
la COP15 vous êtes
l'hôtesse ce qu'on peut dire c'est on
peut dire ça et une grande défenseur
évidemment on veut le succès on veut le
succès c'est pour ça que les villes nous
on s'est mobilisé depuis les derniers
jours pour rappeler aux États
l'importance comment on fait partie de
la solution parce que présentement
beaucoup de choses qui sont implantées
c'est les villes qui est là parce que
sinon citoyens qui vivent les impacts
d'avoir leur sous-sol plein d'eau ou
encore sourire qui perdent leur école ou
autre chose alors nous les maires et moi
la mairesse de Montréal je suis au front
pour rappeler aux États puis rappeler à
tout le monde qu'on a une responsabilité
on va se le dire la vie la nature est
menacée mais la nature ça l'inclut
lui-même ça inclut au mot sapiens nous
aussi on est menacé Valérie plante mais
reste de Montréal merci beaucoup merci
beaucoup à la prochaine